il va très très vite il jouait à purdue
cette année dans la big ten portrait de
draft et de jayden ivy le supersonique
arrière des boys leur makers s'est tout
de suite avec envergure c'est le
générique
[Musique]
avec hugues et alan salut les gars seul
jaden ivy donc j'ai donné sa fiche
d'identité très rapide un arrière on
verra on verra plus tard quel poste on a
envie de le faire jouer en nba mais
d'abord mais d'abord on va essayer de
détail et qui il est d'où il vient et où
il va on le verra après hugues est ce
que tu peux nous donner une idée de son
parcours ouais avec plaisir jade honnête
vis du coup c'est un jour que la plupart
des gens ont découvert soit cet été avec
le u 19 contre tim hug va avec team usa
contre la france soit cette année vu
qu'il a tout explosé mais avant ça st un
mec jacquet a grandi dans une famille de
sportifs lui il était prédestiné à
devenir sportif la maman est là jouer en
wnba la maman et les coachs de n 6 à
notre-dame jeu pour faire plaisir à l'ex
on le place là et puis la maman à la
hâte et assistante sur le bord deux sur
le banc des des memphis grizzlies donc
on est vraiment sur une femme qui a le
basket dans le sang et qui a transmis sa
son fils du côté du paternel le petit
village il a pu grandir avec un joueur
de foot us qui a joué donc en nfl et le
papy et jour de foot us conques amant un
parcours génétique
exceptionnel moi j'aurais bien aimé
avoir le même pour pas ressembler à la
crevette que je suis actuellement le
petit quand il était vraiment enfants il
a fait du foot us qu'il a fait du basket
il a fait du karaté la changer tous les
ans l'impression d'avoir un gamin qui
sait pas trop où il peut se placer tous
les pans il tente des trucs voire du
ping pong et puis après finalement et sa
portée vers le lycée enfin vers le lycée
change vraiment le basket uniquement il
a joué dans l'état de l'indiana où il a
fait son cursus il a rejoint sa dernière
année un des plus gros programme un des
plus gros high school une prep schools
appelle la lumière parce qu'on aime bien
le français les etats unis qui a sorti
pas mal de prospects intéressante il a
rejoint pure audio donc les boilermakers
qui sont une équipe de britten qui a
sorti pas mal de joueurs assez
intéressant assez récemment on a notre
ami khaled soignies gagnent ou pour
donner des cauchemars
alan johnson edwards le formidable chute
au débat stone 7x nous voilà une équipe
un peu référencé première année on
n'entre pas trop parler il est jeune on
est une équipe expérimentée il a une
grosse pression en début de saison aussi
et puis là cette année il explose tout
et maintenant on est sur un joueur on va
le voir qui est candidat au top 10
largement de cette cuvée largement
effectivement mais d'abord avant de
parler de ces projections de ses
qualités on va parler enfin ça va on va
aussi de parler de ses qualités mais on
va parler de son physique à quoi il y à
quoi il ressemble jada il dit quelles
sont ses qualités athlétiques
alan
c'est un joueur qui peut passer déjà je
pense de passer de vitesse dans un laps
de temps super court parce que cela les
pros chose qui saute aux yeux la
capacité d'accélération
ballon en transition quand on lui met un
écran et qui doivent après le split
passer au milieu avec la voile pour
aller au cirque c'est un joueur qui est
c'est un peu un dragster c'est un peu
c'est un peu king c'est common qui
jouent au foot us quoi c'est un qui joue
au basket pardon c'est à dire qu'il est
extrêmement rapide vif tranchant balle
en main c'est ce qui lui permet en fait
de
se faciliter la vie de basketteur en
fait moi c'est la chose que je mets
souvent avancé que pourquoi déjà mort
hante et tous ces gens là c'est plus
simple pour eux ben c'est pas se mettre
c'est tellement des athlètes fou qui se
créé tellement de l'espace sur chaque
prise de balle qu'après moi la passe et
des plus simples le tir il est plus
simple la la la la prise de décision
elles et simplifie et en fait jena lee
grâce à son corps va son explosivité et
son beurre ce qu'on appelle communément
en anglais et ben c'est un genre qui
même s'ils n'étaient pas prédestinées à
porter la balle à créer ou à être un
énorme scoreur ben il peut le faire
parce que se facilite la vie c'est aussi
un joueur qui a une bonne envergure
troupes car il m'a vraiment plus intègre
vraiment intéressant qui fait un peu
plus d'un mètre quatre-vingt-dix
envergure est là de m on a quasiment 10
cm de positif sur sur ça on est un
joueur qui est assez fin mais qui en une
bêche ans pourra défendre les postes 1 2
les porteurs de balle entre 1 m 85 et 1
m 92 stress parce que
dans cette mobilité latéral une ascite
il aura surtout peut-être aussi plus
envie de défendre une billets parce
qu'il aura peut-être moins de
responsabilités tout de suite à une
pièce avec quoi joue le jeu même si
c'était un jeu assez collectif qui
tourne et pendant mon autour de très
bonnes williams à la création au poste
ou avec un autre genre on lui demandait
quand même pas mal d'autant de courir ou
entre les écrans on lui demandait
beaucoup d'efforts physiques donc le
profil des pensées fait aussi est aussi
très intéressant tu disais pour
compléter sur le profil physique peut
alors courir vite c'est bien et ce qui
est ce qu il a une capacité décélération
aussi quelque chose dont on parle de
plus en plus on parle souvent qu'on
parle beaucoup maintenant avec même des
porteurs de balle qui sont pas les plus
tranchants mais qu'arrive à décélérer
c'est un peu le point faible je trouve
de son os pour l'instant ils jouent à il
joua une deux trois vitesses mais quand
il ya la troisième pour repasser à la
deuxième c'est un peu compliqué parfois
donc c'est un axe de travail quand je va
se ralentir aussi pour lui et je pense
que c'est la suite logique de son
développement son appréhension
collective son appréhension de ce que
mais précisons qu'un qui arrive après
avoir fait vraiment la différence balle
en main ça va des sa capacité à pouvoir
desserrer va venir quand il va mieux
appréhender tout ce qui se passe et tout
ce qui génère par ces
alors manu vient de nous rejoindre
juste à temps finalement le l'homme qui
tombe à pic salut manu
on parle de jaden ivy et ma question
pour toi c'est pourquoi c'est un top 10
de draft
on a parlé de son physique de son
histoire
ouais il ya plusieurs choses ces badges
à bord son physique c'est le truc le
plus au ps là dessus il ya rien à dire
une fizi les divas il sera prêt des
wanna avoir un impact sur les types qui
veulent choisir et il a sorti une
envergure aussi qui est super
intéressante pour sa taille l'annoncé à
2,04 alors je sais pas si ça va changer
ou pas
normalement les bras ne pousse pas comme
ça mais un baleineau telle envergure qui
qu'il est des deux côtés du terrain ce
sens et comment un défenseur intéressant
ce que jamais aussi chez lui ce qu'il a
envie de défendre moi je trouve qu'il a
envie de défendre c'est pas un jour qui
seront ou un peu comme à l'époque de la
mort hante cavernes impact offensif
incroyable mais défensivement il n'avait
un burn a secoué
et il est aussi top 10 parce que je
pense qu'il va progresser au tir et dans
la passe là c'est un trait par un bon
passeur mais je pense qu'avec des
coéquipiers meilleurs il va être temps
qui va et le space in game billets ça va
encore plaidé je pense qu'il peut
apporter 6 7 passes décisives de moyenne
sur une saison
très bien donc après je pars revenir sur
le physique est une chose est sûre il ya
quelque chose à dire ouais je fais juste
fait une petite annonce pour les gens
qui nous regardent je vais lancer un un
compteur à référence à jimmy hunt on est
à 2 pour l'instant messieurs dames
d'accord pas dépasser les 10
effectivement c'est la comparaison qui
revient le plus
le côté je vais très vite je saute haut
alors il se sait pas déjà mort et sur la
verticalité même si va très haut il n'y
a pas de problème il va mettre des
grands posters mai mais voilà c'est
évidemment là la comparaison qui revient
le plus dans le style de jeu en tout cas
dans le côté assez époustouflant par la
vitesse en fait puisqu'il ya des moments
où il a il a t'il été flashé à bien plus
de 30 km/heure sur un terrain avec le
ballon ce qui est quand même pas pas
évident contre sur un terrain qui fait
22 29 m je sais plus d'un g j'ai tout
perdu mais mes notions de quand j'étais
arbitres
on parle de ses passes et de son tir qui
est ce qu'il est un porteur de balle
principal est ce qui peut le devenir
qu'est ce qui lui manque aujourd'hui
moi je veux acheter un peu trop de bol
principal portant du plat principal et
pour tout le monde c'est je prends le
ballon
je peux aller au panier je peux créer
mon propre et car je peux faire jouer
les copains je peux appeler un pick and
roll et c'est la bonne décision pour le
moment il a été projeté en fait à
produire en tant que porteur secondaire
mais y'a un meneur assez faible balle en
main il a beaucoup joué sans ballon et
ils avaient des systèmes où c'était
souvent le pivot qui orientait le jeu
prime de willems est un passeur
exceptionnel donc voilà on l'a vu
souvent loin du ballon mais j'achète
effectivement on a des capacités
athlétiques donc un premier pas
pour l'instant il ya un déficit
effectivement sur le peut-être le
changement de changement de direction
sur le changement de vitesse au niveau
de la passe il passa une main toujours
intéressant est passé de l'un des deux
côtés ça j'aime bien capable de faire
une passe directe à une passe lobée de
faire une passe au sol il a un petit peu
pas tunnel vision mais il a des passes
simples pour le moment dans son
répertoire il va pas être hyper à l'aise
pour trouver un mec qui renversa
l'opposé si c'est pas prévu c'est
vraiment un passeur pour l'instant qui
apprend à le devenir plus dont les
combos traditionnels
ils veulent à beaucoup brillé sur drive
and click et ça c'est effectivement les
comparaisons à l'oreille un peu de jo
même si lui s'identifier à ça derrick
rose devrait très très bien wes boucle
font très très bien vraiment je vais au
panier tout le monde essayait de
m'arrêter et donc je renverse à l'opposé
et ça il très à l'aise là dessus son
père son plus gros défaut pour être
important de balle principal en nba on
va pouvoir développer peut-être dessus
c'est le fait de se créer un écart pour
lui moi ça je pense que c'est vraiment
sa grosse difficulté actuellement
surtout sur le tir sur le mi distance ou
le trois points où on n'a pas un joueur
qui est très à l'aise sur un steve bacon
n'a pas joueur qui est très à l'aise sur
un stade staples ou du stop and pool il
ya un manque de toucher il ya un manque
de fluidité là dessus donc sciemment
même quand on est entre la ligne à trois
points et le panier qu'est ce qui peut
faire c'est ça qu'il faut travailler
avec lui je pense jaden et will i tunes
dont on pourra donc mes excuses
je pars au freestyle
manu est ce que tu tues tu es d'accord
avec ça et comment tu voit son tir en
fait mécaniquement et
et avec plusieurs nuances de mouvements
etc je sais que tu te tais tu fais
partie des gens qui ont
apprécié l'évolution cette année du tir
de jaden ivy way armand contrairement
aux préférences second initiateurs par
contre je trouve que ça lui permette de
montrer son potentiel de l'optimiser à
fond étant un passeur est il pour
arriver en vitesse vers le cercle et
tout du catch and shoot à trois points
aussi ai-je parce que je pense que c'est
un peu [ __ ] de code le m initiateur
numéro un et je le vois pas forcément
avoir un c'est pas un rôle où ce que
fait don teach qui fait que porter la
balle pendant 35 secondes et finalement
qu'un petit mot qui va pas apprécier à
l'anis c est lyon centre est et ce qu'il
faut pas faire ça pour moi surtout que
trois autres assure que ça change
voilà exactement sa valeur pour moi faut
pas le bris des galas faut laisser
courir pour qu'il aille à un maximum
vers le cercle en fait et du coup pour
revenir à la question
sur le désir que tu me l'a rappelé dans
le tir le tir je suis la mécanique je
pas fan c'est vraiment moi ce qui me
gêne je trouve que ça part vraiment d'un
peu trop bas à l'heure actuelle nous ce
qui ce qui l'empêchent pas justement ce
qu'ils disent est une ode tout à l'heure
c'est de s'arrêter et de pouvoir poulet
pas en course de pouvoir couleurs plus
généralement fait vu que sa mécanique un
peu tendancieuse des fois ça ça le
pénalise là dedans et je peux mais je
pense que c'est un peu à l'image d'un
kennedy john leur qui vraiment tiré
assez bas aussi on ice cool carmelo res
à rien quand on est en en était raté ni
si je pense que là au jour le jour avec
un staff nba
ça va être réglé assez assez vite ce ça
va être améliorée à ciel rapidement je
pense donc je me fais pas de jeu pas
inquiet là dessus
alan est ce que tu as déjà vu une
évolution de ce tir
est-ce que et où tu te positionnes sur
reporter primaire porter secondaire
parce que c'est une question importante
parce que je pense que ça conditionne
aussi la la place où on le met sur le
classement des big board
complètement il peut être porteur
primaire mais ça sera pas d'une bonne
équipe au début je pense
mais il peut le faire parce que comme
vous aviez son physique et toutes les
différences qu'il crée et les manières
de tours et c'est de l'arrêter font qu'
il va pouvoir s'ouvrir des fêtes de
passe un peu un peu plus simple que les
autres parce que je pense pas que c'est
un passeur naturel c'est pas quelqu'un
qui prend les meilleures décisions sur
pick'n roll encore qu'à prendre
parfaitement donc sauvé de cire magasin
problème ces deux pourcentages de citron
parce que
partage aux lancers francs en deux ans a
peu à peu en dessous 7 74% sur le
charisme 5 natif par ma team usa s
étaient 16 sur 23 aux u19 donc même pas
70% mais d'un côté il y avait cette
progression au tir il y passe de 25% à
35% propres entre les deux années et où
beaucoup de gens avaient mis en avant
qui sont regardés les chiffres à la
lumière en stage à trois points c'était
très positif sur le tir donc il ya un
peu les deux on aime bien essayer dans
l'argument du lancer franc souvent pour
le touché c'est avec ses quelque chose
d'important mais en même temps il semble
progresser quand même et avoir eu
toujours des des bon pour trois points
je pense qu'une mine chose qu'un plus
galvaudé c'est important de balle il a
besoin de tourner à plus de 35% à 3
points validés parce que parce qu'en
fait deux choses il va prendre des tirs
compliqué donc pas mal de bouloc donc si
déjà il y à 34 35 c'est bien et
deuxièmement et c'est que je ce que
j'adore c'est de la vie d'une alice et
ses 52% à 3 à 2 points sur en carrière
ancien joueur qui peut c'est pas un des
ventes et g c'est pas un commu iste
c'est pas ces gens qui sont que dans le
club parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à finir
à 2 points et donc je pense que ce
profil là peut faire de lui en portant
de balle principale ou secondaire qui
finit bien de points finit bien en
cercle et à 7,7 se voulait pas trop
plein qui se développent et là où je
vais rajouter je pense qu'elle est
didier que je peux confirmer aussi c'est
que du côté de purdue la moitié de ces
tirs à trois points c'est du catch and
shoot et c'est très souvent des sorties
d'écran il a fait beaucoup de flou pi2
système vraiment de floppy il sera
extrait bien donc il peut vraiment jouer
loin du ballon durant les premières
années il ya aucun problème là-dessus
non au niveau du tir la seule difficulté
c'est que on en parlait dans le podcast
sur chet lui latéralisation quand même
qui a s'est mise en avant au niveau du
catch and shoot c'est que dès que le
ballon arrive sur sa main gauche ou des
qui va faire un renversement sur côté
droit à ce moment là les pourcentages et
je suis drastiquement on passe de 40%
voyez du catch and shoot au niveau de la
main droite à 25% et donc il a un vrai
problème mécanique de réac c'est le
ballon et de leur pouvoir déclencher nos
qui d'habitude motrices à travailler
largement au niveau supérieur pour
pouvoir exister chance au secteur là et
même dans l'ensemble
moi j'ai peu de souvenirs de de lui qui
termine
avec le dernier appuie droit planté au
cercle c'est à dire qu'il va terminer il
va il va prendre deux pieds il va faire
dernier pied pied gauche pour monte au
dunk mai dernier appuie droit je suis
pas j'ai peu de souvenirs de ça je pense
qu'il a une grosse préférence motrices
sur effectivement dernière dernier
appuie gauche qui peut expliquer aussi
cette différence aux tirs
on parle de son ca ted
hughes nous l'a dit dans son portrait et
fils de d'une maman qui est qui qui est
le basket dans le sang et dans la tête
athlète côté papa donc ce
professionnalisme on va dire il le
connaît il a déjà ça fonctionne souvent
bien maintenant est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous avez vu vous on vous en omettant ce
contexte sur le terrain en dehors du
terrain alan mois déjà j'ai vu elle
contacte imusa est d'un joueur qui a été
vraiment capable parlement de laisser la
balle aux autres et de tête vraiment un
slasher quêteurs
fort défenseur avec team usa et j'adore
ça parce que ne peut pas avoir tous les
rôles on n'a nulle part un timbre qui
pouvait pas quitter fort n'est pas me
respectent et c'est vrai que avec des
fonds n'est pas un point il faisait 50 %
des passifs quand il est sur le terrain
glisse ici personne ne pouvait rien
faire d'autre auxi défendez pas ça me
dérangeait pas là il y avait un rôle
offensif très important avec tu mets
aussi on l'a vu vraiment défendre on a
vu très agressif assez vocal je trouvais
d'ailleurs dans cette équipe de team usa
qui était encore à l'époque je trouvais
le thé se vante en fait plus un an après
en fait barria il ya quand même pas mal
de joueurs qui vont être drafté de cette
équipe a donc elles n'étaient pas si
décevante que ça mais dans cette équipe
là bas il finit d'anciens de la compet
il est décisif c'était vraiment des
inarrêtable sur pas mal de tout ce qui
est kate et tout ça est en fait j'ai
trouvé que bah ça se voit qu'ils se
voient qu'il veut il est dans un
aspect de là je veux je veux je veux
gagner je suis prêt à me
laisser la balle à kitchener aux autres
genres qu'elle est avec la balle dans
cette équipe-là gros pot pour le bien
équipe pour gagner
je pense que c'est aussi ça se ressent
aussi dans le box office de fist coach
si c'est la maman souvent c'est pas la
maman c'est plutôt le pavois balas et
fils de coach mais
vraiment pas de red flag sur le sur le
comportement sur les i télé tout je
trouve que c'est ça l'a vraiment d'être
qui l'intéressé la tête sur les épaules
manu ouais moi je suis assez d'accord
aussi c'est qu'on voit sur les idoles
sur les temps morts etc où il est
vraiment impliqués dont avec l'équipe il
est vraiment vocal aussi il parle
beaucoup moi j'aime vraiment ça sera
important aussi pas être focus
uniquement sur le basket et le cas
l'aspect hors terrain sur le banc et
c'est super intéressant et le trouve
vraiment krine là dessus honnêtement
donc et je pense que le background
familial
l'aide aussi et ils ont appris à garder
la tête sur les épaules et la tête
froide et savoir ce qu'il faut faire en
fait vraiment où partout et intelligente
en basket en général je la tue je suis
pas inquiet quand même que ça peut
l'aider sur les interviews pré-draft ou
post paul draft
sûr avec les gm les coaches tout à
gagner des points ci doit en gagner face
à peut faire pencher la balance en
assurant avec un gm qui va adorer le
profil ce genre de choses et hugues
nounou note dans notre chat privé
effectivement c'est quelqu'un qui aime
prendre les gros shoots à la fin il
tient qu'à pas peur d'avoir le ballon
dans les moments chauds donc ça c'est
aussi la marque de personnes qui sont
prêtes pour le haut niveau
parlons si vous voulez bien de la
défense on a déjà dit plusieurs mots
mais mais j'aimerais en savoir plus
parce que c'est important de
ces paraître bête dit comme ça mais
c'est voilà c'est très important
surtout pour gagner des minutes au début
même s'il en aura probablement de
defacto ne pas être un boulet défensif
pour son équipe
d'autant que lui il est pas encore on
espère qu'il deviendra un plus plus plus
offensif donc il faut il faut qu'ils
tiennent la route défensivement
quelles sont ses qualités ou quelles
sont ces ces limitations et quel genre
de joueur il peut défendre il va
défendre
effectivement manu disait je pensais
défendre les postes 1 2 en tout cas pour
moi il peut défendre les mecs qui vont
jouer le piquet ne peut défendre ce
qu'on aime bien appeler le point sauf
attaque qui a été un peu plus notre
vocabulaire envergure commence à peu
près à utiliser ce à toutes les sauces
il peut j'aime bien sa capacité à
traverser les écrans je trouve que quand
il se donne les moyens de le faire et
c'est pas tout le temps le cas et encore
une fois d'un contexte collectif où il
peut pas tout faire non plus mais qu'on
se donne les moyens de le faire sur les
séquences importantes dans les matches
décisifs il est capable de traverser
l'écran il utilise bien ses longueurs de
segments pour pouvoir casser les hands
off pour pouvoir empêcher le mec de
vraiment passé bien travers l'écran
j'aime bien sa capacité aussi à
reconnaître c'est ton porteur de balle
adverse il ya un tireur à trois points
club qui peut tirer derrière l'écran ou
bien si ça driver est ce qu'il peut
driver main droite main gauche j'aime
pas ça chez avis il sert collation
scouting report il sait qu'un mec ya pas
de main gauche bomba vas-y tu peux
passer sous l'écran et un témoin gauche
voilà donc il ya quand même une maturité
la suite défensif pas mal trop souvent
porté sur le ballon à mes yeux et ça
c'est un défaut de jeunesse et ça peut
totalement se régler mais il peut se
faire prendre sur des démarquages à
l'opposé sur des démarquages ligne de
fond là dessus il ya peu avoir des
petits problèmes c'est un joueur que je
trouve en qh est vraiment bien le
contact donc si jamais on va se
retrouver à switcher un poste plus grand
il peut prendre un premier impact sur un
ailier je te dis pas qui peut switcher
tous les ailiers mais il peut prendre un
premier impact peut-être tenir attendre
que la dalle arrivent ils à la détente
verticale pour pouvoir ensuite finir sur
un contre en second rideau donc voilà il
ya une belle mobilité une belle
latéralité une bonne gestion du contact
le vat moi le point décisif ça va être
son focus sur 48 minutes et surtout dans
une équipe qui perd est-ce qu'il va
réussir à garder ça et ça ça va
peut-être qu'ils prennent pour lui
oui il a des épaules ans tu parlais du
contact il ay là il a un vrai physique
presque de vous de foot us 1 moi je mets
cortège du pardon
c'est ça me met avec qui tu ne fais pas
cette question en tout cas avec ma femme
je le fais ça te donne une idée du
personnage que je suis
à l'âne on parlait tout à l'heure porter
principal porteur secondaire
ou tulle draft toi est ce que pour toi
il fait partie du groupe du fameux
groupe des quatre avec une graine
jabbari smith et paolo band hero est ce
qu'il est un cran en dessous
ou tu le classe par rapport à celle
d'une chape dont on a déjà parlé
voilà et comme comment tu l'évaluent jay
denney vie moi je sais pas un groupe de
quatre géants un groupe de deux coups un
groupe de quatre jargon de deux que je
retouche parler dans l'épisode sur
church et et pour le bunker au et
ensuite j'ai un groupe de quatre tués
denali jeune charles javari smith et
hadji
je n'arrive il est le premier de ce
groupe là que je resterai honnêtement
c'est le premier ça pourrait chat un
chat mais j'ai même si j'adore chez les
sharks avec manu on en parle à la fois
on a vu quand on a quand même vu pas mal
de matches de lui on connaît même si on
j'ai plus de garanties avec cheese de
nagui et je pense que même s'il a un an
et demi de plus que de nay vie
c'est un jeune sophos et souffre dans
son jeu et dans sa maturité
c'est un jeune sophomore fraîche du vois
je dois pas si il est pas finie pour moi
donc ça me dérange pas de draft et en
droit et en fait je trouve que ses
capacités athlétiques ses capacités de
nos premiers pas hyper virevoltant ça
fait que ça va lui faciliter la vie de
biais et donc je le posera pas ce que je
peux lui donner la balle je peux le
faire jouer loin du ballon je peux le
faire défendre à une polyvalence et des
deux côtés du terrain qui pour moi est
plus importante qu'un jabbari si mesquin
donc je pense que je peux drafter et
john a évidement devant ces gens là manu
comment tu le compares à ces joueurs là
rapport à la valeur que ça aussi
aujourd'hui en nba d'avoir un gars qui
peut peut jouer avec qui peut jouer sur
le ballon et qui peut jouer un petit peu
sans aussi puisque toi tu le vois jouer
en secondaire
mais moi j'ai dans mon tir de aussi plus
ou moins avec les mêmes types de joueurs
mais en fait ce qui est intéressant avec
lui c'est qu'on sait ce qu'on aura déjà
ses seins elle place le plancher et à
ses hôtes déjà avec ce qu'on a ça c'est
intéressant et ça donne des garanties au
mai sur le potentiel
moi je préfère qu'on a ce que je disais
sur le podcast de sharp veut prendre un
sharp avant avant un avis mais c'est un
avis complètement personnel et
alana couple inverse tu peux avoir
l'inversé si toi aussi
voir d'autres joueurs donc
là dessus je en fait on bouge moi je
reste là dessus on sait ce que je sais
ce que j'ai donc là tu déjà c'est un oui
c'est positif et il peut être que
meilleur temps ce qu'il sait faire c'est
l'auris hybrid world ouais voilà
complètement et peut-être que du coup un
gm qui a un peu la pression il va plus
se tourner vers ce genre de profil eu
que tu penses que c'est moins risqué de
draft et à heavy que drafté banque quéro
que drafté jabbari smith qu drafté de
shelton grain
bonne queiroz n'ont pas ce que je te dis
pour ma 22 euros il peut arriver demain
nba [ __ ] 17 18 ans donc voilà elle vit
effectivement il peut il peut porter le
ballon il peut jouer sans le symbole
donc il peut vraiment s'intégrer un peu
partout dans tout l'est dans toutes les
équipes alors encore une fois ce flic
chine ce qu'on doit 3000 bollène l'heure
donc reprenez pas un bollène l'heure
s'il vous plaît faites partager aux
copains mais et en plus il a la rareté
du professeur cette draft beaucoup
critiqué les baleines lors de la draft
c'est le premier qui va partir s'ils ont
omis bonne quéro donc toutes les équipes
un char pellin chaque partie
moi je te dis je dis je je sais que je
ne sais rien c'est mon côté socrates ya
et je trouve par rapport à ce que j'ai
pu en voir quand même parce que j'ai un
petit échantillon sur cinq matches deux
lycées du team canada c'est que je
préfère la capacité de david aller au
panier donc pour moi même si le tir suis
pas particulièrement dès le début bon
bah tu peux le faire que tu es tu peux
lui dire vas-y ya une ligne ouverte
fonceur engorgent autres là dedans et
m'aider mais des gros tomar donc tu peux
le faire jouer très rapidement en nba et
effectivement je pense que le potentiel
à terme est très excitant et même si
tulle en couveuse hand-ball alors
secondaire tu peux espérer avoir un
symbole de leur primaire au bout de
trois quatre ans et a une grosse
valeureux nba dernière question quel
construction autour du prospect qu'elle
quel profil il faut à côté de lui
qu'elle arrière qu'elle est liée quel
type de pivot qu'est ce qui serait bien
pour son développement et au contraire
qu est ce qui serait préjudiciable à la
neige ça à paraître bête mais je veux
des joueurs intelligents
que déjà extrêmement intelligent plus
plus que parce qu'en fait je pense que
lui juste parce que par stratégie qui va
pouvoir se créé tellement de choses
simples il va pouvoir vraiment créer des
différences action après action
quart-temps après quart temps que en
fait j'ai l'illumination du bac courte
halliburton a heavy donc il resterait
dans l'état de l'indiana ce n'est pas
très drôle s'il a envie de partir
ailleurs je crois que s'il a envie de
déménager mais quand j'aurai bien le
mettre à côté d'un autre garde qui très
fort en catch and shoot qui peut donc
réceptionné le drive in teak de jada
ellie et qui peut à la fois créé sur
pick'n roll pour trouver des danaïdes
loin du ballon sur des couples trouvait
déjà rivés sur le drive et nikki jim
wales ou super complémentarité avec un
autre beau l'aisne l'eure parce qu'en
réalité
comme l'a dit manu s'était pas la
meilleure idée de les mettre tout de
suite en tant que créateur numéro un
comme si d'ailleurs c'est pas la
muraille et le match est un brain tout
seul au point ce cinq ans et des jeunes
joueurs ils vont arriver à une bille est
pas la meilleure y tournait pas luca
quoi tout le monde n'est pas ces jours
là donc je pense qu'avec un autre forme
holender serait très intéressant ou
alors un fort ailier parce qu'un fort
ailier du drive in teak tu mets à côté
de lui un joueur qui est super
virevoltant balle en main bip qui peut
quand même prendre des décisions ce
serait la mienne je suis pas persuadé
qu'il faut de ces sucettes super voix à
l'intérieur au dessus je pense que jean
avis ça sera plus un joueur qui va
exceller avec un autre garde fort où en
est donc un fort rally mais pas un
ailier fort du coup
juste une blague d'accord ok alaton
excuse-moi excuse moi
le palau bang héros c'est un ailier fort
reparlerai
manu est ce que tu es d'accord avec alan
est ce que tu as le même diagnostic
plus ou moins d'accord et c'est pour ça
que je l'équipe possiblement qui peut le
draft et j'aimais bien à la nouvelle
orléans avec mc collum
mettre les deux ensemble sur un bac orge
trouve que c'est assez complémentaires
parce que les deux peuvent porter la
balle vous sur du 50-50 par exemple quoi
sur plusieurs séquences et je trouve ça
un super intéressant après fo s'écoute
de la complémentarité avec ben zion est
ce qu'il va pouvoir lui ses cartes et on
ne sait pas ce qui advient ce qu'il en
est de son foot on s'est un peu un peu
un point noir sur la dessus autrement il
y avait au cas ici avec avec shai
sait où c'est plus ou moins la même
chose c'est eux les deux peuvent porter
la balle les
mets ta guider quoi c'est ça le problème
avec
lui mais moi si j'ai eu le bac our time
fichiers mp3
je pense que ça ne dérange pas de faire
sortir du banc à evil ou un guide
au début je pense que
c'est jouable quoi
j'ai vu pas mal de tweets passé qui le
réclamaient à detroit bah ouais aussi
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour qu'il y
ait après alan payen une équipe
intelligente de joueurs intelligents là
c'est un peu moins qu'à lui vaut c'était
dur
un sur les 5 6 et compan qui
l'avantagent a dit choix dit que tu peux
redécollé qu'eads sur des post est liée
surtout fois des fonctions des ailiers
et que tu peux lui mettre deux gardes
derrière un catch and shoot heures jour
les postes en deux ans peut-être que qui
viennent peut devenir et aubord pourtant
des balles après comme ça secondaire et
tu as vraiment une équipe hyper à une
pied moderne et hyper excitant défection
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter ou est-ce qu'on va clore ce
dossier jayden juste pour les fans moi
je à indiana j'ai fait un une
billettique et 22 ça m'a fait ça fait
dix ans que j'ai pas joué à une diète ou
qu'est lancé un match m indiana avec
halliburton champions première saison
voilà je dis ça c'est une bonne tête des
indications sur quoi faire c'est viable
à peu près à 2% ok bah c'est bon en fait
c'est hugues a vu l'avenir donc donc
tout va bien vous savez vous ça fait
quoi faire je précise qu'on enregistre
ce podcast
avant
le tirage de la loterie ce qui pourrait
expliquer d'éventuels anachronisme
puisqu'il devrait sortir après sur ce
messieurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce podcast se profile de
draft de jayden ivy on vous donne rendez
vous sur notre site envergure penser aux
alesi partagé fait tourner les scouts
inri portes y en a plus de 60 70 on
devrait arriver à 100 à la fin abonnez
vous sur votre plateforme d' écoute on
est partout deezer spotify stitcher
apple podcast on est partout dont il
suffit de vous abonner pour avoir la
petite motifs quand le podcast sort
abonnez vous également sur youtube vous
avez été très nombreux à écouter en fait
le podcast sur chat au grain sur youtube
donc n'hésitez pas et puis sur youtube
il va y avoir beaucoup de live d'ici la
draft donc voilà des lives équipe par
équipe des lives généraux et peut-être
des interviews on va beaucoup utilisé
youtube suivez-nous la page envergure
pod suivez-nous également sur instagram
merci à tous de nous avoir écoutés ou
donnent rendez-vous au prochain poteau